adopté mardi dernier à l'assemblée
nationale la loi de solidarité urbaine
ne fait pas que des heureux
elle impose à toutes les communes la
construction de 20 % de logements
sociaux des quotas impossible à
atteindre répondre certaines communes le
reportage d'olivier thiêt et christine
donato qui sont allés au raincy en
seine-saint-denis et à villeneuve la
garenne dans les hauts de seine regarder
vivre dans un logement social au raincy
c'est un peu la vie de château
ici pas de tours hlm en béton mais des
pavillons et les villes à réhabiliter le
problème c'est que la commune compte à
peine 3 % de logements sociaux pour se
mettre en conformité avec la loi gayssot
il faudrait en construire 800 de plus
pour la ville c'est mission impossible
il n'y a plus de surface constructible
et à 15000 francs le mètre carré
difficile de rivaliser avec les
promoteurs pour acheter au prix du
marché
alors au raincy on se prépare déjà à
payer les pénalités prévues par la loi
mille francs par logement manquant
l'erreur de la loi gayssot c'est que
plutôt que de me donner la main on me
montre du doigt il faudra demain
construire 50 à 55 logements sociaux par
an sans m'aider beaucoup plus c'est à
dire que je ne peux pas faire en sorte
que sur ma ville le poids financier de
cet effort supplémentaire soit accepté
changement de décor nous sommes à
villeneuve-la-garenne ici la polémique
autour de la loi gayssot fait un peu
sourire
la commune compte en effet près de 80 %
de logements sociaux
l'objectif de la ville serait plutôt de
réhabiliter son parc hlm comme ici dans
le quartier de la caravelle mais aussi
de répartir le poids de ses dépenses
sociales avec les communes plus riches
ce que je propose c'est toutes les
villes qui ont déjà plus de 20% de
logements sociaux
toutes ces villes là bénéficient
directement des pénalités versées par
les villes qui n'ont pas assez de
logements sociaux et que sept
ce reversement se fasse de façon
progressive
la loi sur la solidarité urbaine
concerne 178 commune en ile de france
elles ont 20 ans pour rattraper leur
retard en matière de logement social